[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
DOMINIQUE GISIN:
So hi, everybody.
It's a great pleasure to be here
at Google center in Switzerland
and talk a little bit
about my past, my present,
and my future, and share
my experience so far, some
of the emotions and, hopefully,
some of the learnings, as well.
Well, everything started off
when I was pretty short still.
I was 1 and 1/2 years old
when I started to ski.
Can you imagine?
I could barely walk,
and then I skied.
My mom still says I actually
ski better than I walk,
and I must admit,
she's probably right.
And as you can see
already on this picture,
I always had a big,
big smile on my face.
Because skiing is
really the world to me.
It's my first childhood memory.
It's really everything
I care about,
and it's just the
best thing there is.
And I think this
picture says it all.
I went on to become a
professional skier, started
in several regional ski races,
started to win national ski
races on a kid's level.
You know, all the
steps everybody
does who wants to
become an athlete.
In skiing it means every year
a new category, other athletes
that you compete with,
and I made step by step
towards world class.
Everything looked
perfectly fine.
When I was 14 I was one of
the best in Switzerland.
I was already
representing Switzerland
at international races.
I went to a race to
Sarajevo with the plane.
It was an extreme
experience for me,
you know, going to the
airport with all the luggage
and everything, and then
competing with the best.
And I figured out I don't
only love the sport and skiing
and the winter, I also
love the lifestyle
of traveling, living out of
a suitcase, and especially,
comparing myself to the best
athletes all over the world.
When I was 14, I also
got my first injury.
Somebody asked me before if
I ever had an ACL injury.
Of course I had an ACL injury,
like every skier has or almost
every skier has, unfortunately.
I tore my ACL at my right knee.
After that I got several
complication surgeries,
because we just couldn't
figure out what went wrong
after the first surgery.
Rehab was perfect.
Year after in the
control, we found out
that I suffered a broken
patella, something
that happens if you
take your patella tendon
as a replacement of your ACL.
It happens very seldom.
That's why the doctors
couldn't figure it out.
After that, I went
through another set
of surgery setbacks.
It was a crazy time
of struggle and living
in a world where there was
pretty much only sleeping,
eating, rehab, and that was it.
I wasn't skiing competitional
for more than three years,
between the age of 15 and 18.
Now, this is the
age everybody talks
about when we want
to figure out who's
going to make it in
professional sports and who not.
Because it's the time where
everything gets decided.
And that's the time where
I didn't even compete.
Let's not even talk about
being on the podium,
because if you're not on
the start, I can tell you,
it's pretty hard to
end up on a podium.
So somehow I made
it through that time
with the help of an
amazing medical setback,
like surrounding, who will
support me extremely well.
I was lucky enough to
have a series of injuries
that was interesting to the
best surgeons in the world.
Funny, but true.
I tore my patella and
my patella tendon,
and because the whole structure
was already pretty damaged,
the whole muscle was
ripped out as well.
And this complicated
injury is not even
written down in any book.
It doesn't even have a name.
My doctor who fixed it
is Dr. Segesser, one
of the most famous knee
surgeons in Switzerland.
And he said he never
had something like it.
So you can imagine that it was
a pretty big deal coming back
from that.
Now, three years later, many
injuries, many setbacks,
still working on my comeback
and getting back to world class.
And this time, not on slalom
and giant slalom like I
did as a kid, but on
the speed disciplines.
Who's skiing fan in the room?
Anybody looking ski--
OK, most.
So we have different
disciplines.
You know that-- downhill,
super G, giant slalom, slalom.
Giant slalom, slalom
is a little slower,
a little easier, but
technically, pretty amazing.
And speed is speed.
Downhill and super G--
it's straight down,
fast as you can go.
And--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DOMINIQUE GISIN: Exactly.
Exactly.
And I was always a
giant slalom and slalom
kid, because my childhood
hero was Vreni Schneider.
Anybody still knows
Vreni Schneider?
Yes, thank you.
She was my childhood hero.
She won everything
in those disciplines.
But coming back from the
injury, I had two problems.
First problem was,
my knee was so weak,
and especially my
fast twitching muscles
were so weak that I
couldn't do slalom anymore.
I couldn't get out of the
turn fast enough to get speed
for the whole course.
And the second problem,
which was much bigger
was, I had to start bib 139,
and all my friends were already
gone in the next, next, next
upper category, because they
went through the whole
process of getting better
in the start list, three years.
And I had none of
those three years left.
So I was there at the starting
gate with the last bib.
And in giant slalom and slalom,
if you have the last bib,
you will not even see
the gates sometimes,
because the holes that
the people in front of you
have carved through
the snow, they
are so big that you have trouble
seeing where you have to go.
And I can tell you, you
will lose some time.
So we say 30 bibs is
approximately one second back.
So if you're starting
with 139, you all
can calculate very well.
You wouldn't be here
if you wouldn't.
So I will not do
the calcs for you,
but I can guarantee you will not
win a race with bib number 139.
Not even Mikaela Shiffrin, and
I think she's amazing, but not
even Mikaela Shiffrin will win
a race with bib number 139.
In downhill and super
G, things are different.
because everybody's just
going straight down,
there are no holes
carved in the snow,
and you can win with
the very last bib.
And I went to Cortina
for a race in downhill.
All the coaches
said my coach was
nuts to let me go down there,
because I was already injured,
with 80 kilometers per hour.
And now they were like, you
really want to let her go 120?
And we did it, and I
made it to the finish,
and Italian speaker got
crazy, and I got second place.
And it was amazing.
And the best thing about
it was that I qualified
for Austrian championships.
Now understanding how
this slide's coming there.
Sounds weird, but in skiing,
national championships
are always international races.
And you know the fight that the
Swiss have with the Austrians
in skiing?
Heard about it, maybe?
If you never heard about
it, you hear it now.
It's very friendship-like,
but it's still a fight.
We want those points,
they want our points,
and we try to get there
and really beat them.
So when I showed up there
without a team jacket,
nobody knew who I was.
The Austrians
laughed pretty hard.
They stopped laughing when
I won one of the races,
and I became Austrian champion.
Not for real, but
the points were mine,
and that was what was counted.
After that, things went crazy.
I went to my first
World Cup race,
was clocking the best time in
my very first downhill official
training ever.
It was a big show.
The whole mountain was amazed,
except for the Austrians.
They said, well, she's
Austrian champion.
They can take the positive
out of everything.
You got to give it to them.
And then world
championships in Are--
that was one hell
of an experience.
I mean, going to Sweden and then
racing in this scenery, which
was just out of this world.
And I was amazed that suddenly
the people that were on TV
before were standing on
the starting gate with me.
And I went out there
and I charged a course.
I got a fifth place and I
was completely devastated,
because I wanted
that medal so bad.
But if I think back now, it
was my first world champs.
I got fifth.
I should have been happy,
but I wasn't, I can tell you.
But things went great
and I was really excited.
And then I have one other
big, big passion in my life,
and it's flying.
And flying, for me, is
something so essential,
because it recharges
my batteries.
And I don't know
how you guys are,
but I can imagine you
have pretty tough work,
pretty lots to do.
If I remember the timings when
regional sent me some mails,
it was pretty late sometimes.
So I think it is so important
for each and every one of us
to have times when you work,
but also times when you
can recharge your batteries.
Because energy is
crucial, you know?
And you can never do
good work if you're tired
and you're exhausted and
there's nothing left.
So to have a place
where I can go,
and no matter what, I know I
can recharge my batteries there,
it's so essential to me.
And that's what flying is.
And yeah, if you
see that picture,
I hope, like the first skiing
picture, it's the same, right?
Big smiles and pure
freedom, to me.
So flying is where
I get the energy
to make the next big steps, and
next big steps led me to Sochi.
After another eight
or so injuries,
there were constant struggles,
still, when I was in World Cup.
Every time I looked
out of the hole--
you know how you feel when
you look out of a hole
after you dig deep,
and do you think,
now I'm going to make it,
there was another hammer coming.
And I really thought that this
was just the story of my life.
And then I was in Sochi.
And the night before the
race, I was constantly
thinking that, why?
Why should it be
like that, right?
And then suddenly, I
was like, you know what?
The 17-year-old Dominique
would be so ashamed
if she could see you now,
complaining about having
the biggest chance of her life.
And then something
switched inside me,
and I knew, OK, I have this
chance to win this medal,
I so want to do it.
And the day after
I got that gold
that I was working for
for such a long time.
And it was such a wonderful day,
and it means so, so much to me,
because of course,
a gold is a gold,
and it's always the same
color, but mine was really
drowned in blood and sweat
and tears, many tears.
And it means so much more
to you to achieve something
like that after all
the struggles and all
the setbacks and all the fights
I had to go through in my life.
So yeah, that's Sochi.
And then what was next?
I needed a new challenge, right?
I was always about going
for my full potential.
You ever had that feeling
that what is like,
getting you up in the
morning is like just
exploring how far can I go.
How good can I
become in what I do?
And in skiing, there was a point
after Sochi where I realized,
there is nothing
left I can adapt.
There is nothing left I
can adjust to get better.
I have nothing left
for the next summer
to change to become
a better skier.
And it's not about the results.
Because yes, of course, I could
have waited for another two
or three years and hope
that some would retire,
and some would
maybe get injured,
because it's pretty common
in our sports, unfortunately.
But it's about what
fulfills me, and it's not
the black and white
results in the end,
those are the things
that are watching out
that I can pay my food in
the end of the month, right?
And I know figures and
facts are important,
and we all have to set goals and
then show that we accomplished
those goals.
But what is getting
me up in the morning
is really exploring
how far can I go.
How far can I become
a better skier,
and now how far can
I go with my studies.
And I always wanted
to study physics.
And I don't know how I came
to the idea to go to ETH.
I don't know if it was
the best idea of my life.
It sure was three
years of new challenges
that didn't feel much
less energy taking
than all the skiing and
all the injuries before,
and it was a
completely new setup.
If you go studying with almost
30, and half of your class
is 15-year-old
super kids who just
finished their high school
early, I can tell you,
it's a challenge.
And I remember in the first
month I was sitting there,
and I never knew if I should
listen to the professor,
if I should try to understand
what he's talking about,
or if I should just write
down whatever he is saying.
And I knew that I
had to choose one,
because two simultaneous
is just impossible,
and I most times ended up with
doing nothing and just getting
stressed out that I
could not figure out
what was the best to do.
So it was completely different.
And then also,
before, I was a skier,
and I was outside every
day in the weather.
And of course it's tough when
you go outside and it's raining
and you have to train all
day, but then starting at ETH
and being inside all day,
and never even seeing the sun
or what the weather was like,
wasn't much better either.
So it was the complete
opposite-- living
in the city to living
in the mountains.
Sitting down all day, to
before, training 45 hours
a week or something.
If you could have had the
opposite of my life as a skier,
that was it.
And my body struggled with it.
My hormones struggled with it.
I could not deal with it.
I was completely overwhelmed.
And only after a
year I figured out,
OK, I have to find
a way in between.
I need to move my body.
I can't just do all the homework
until I go do some sports.
Because I don't know how
many of you studied at ETH,
but I'm pretty sure you all
studied at crazy universities.
And I never finished my
homework in three years.
There was always
something left to do.
So if I would have
waited for it,
I would never have
done any sports.
And I realized I need
to do sports just
to recharge my batteries
again, and also
to give my body some movement.
I mean, it's crucial, right?
And I just finished my studies,
my bachelor this summer,
and I will take
a break from ETH.
And of course, skiing
is still my passion.
I mean, I love skiing.
I love snow.
This is the time of the year.
I just hope the
temperatures drop,
and I understand each
and everyone living
in the city that
doesn't feel like that.
But you just should come up
to the mountains a bit more
in winter.
It's pretty amazing.
So I'm still skiing
50 days plus a year.
I'm joining my sister on
her path to also, hopefully,
a lot of World Cup podiums.
She also became Olympic
champion last year,
something super crazy to
have two Olympic champions
in the same family, and to share
the emotions was something that
will always stay in my heart.
Because as an athlete,
you just always
have this filter of
pushing down your emotions
a little bit so you can
perform at your best.
And if you're the sister,
you can just let it out.
You can live the emotions,
which is something very, very
beautiful.
And now a new challenge
since October 1,
so pretty much at the
beginning, I got new work.
I'm sharing management of the
Stiftung Schweizer Sporthilfe.
It's the biggest
organization in Switzerland
who supports our top athletes.
It's very crucial support.
We're sharing [SPEAKING GERMAN],,
doing the management together.
Doris Rechsteiner is
doing it for many years,
and we appreciate her
amazing experience,
and she helps us get
all our crazy ideas
into the right direction.
And the support
of our presidents
Urs and Bernhard is amazing.
They are both sports
fanatics, like we all are.
And we're really hoping
that we can move something.
What do we have to
move in Switzerland?
Top athletes are paid
completely different
than in other countries.
Most countries have systems,
where the athletes are somehow
employed by government
in any kind of way.
In Switzerland, it's different.
We support them
on three pillars.
We also have the
Swiss Bund Federation,
who is supporting us through
the lottery money, which
is extremely important for us.
And then we have, of
course, a lot of business
who is supporting us.
And we have each and
every one of you,
who hopefully will
join this movement,
because we believe that we
all should do something.
So we will still have the
motions and the experience
of having Swiss top
athletes also in the future
and that we can sit in front
of TV and cheer them on,
because we have to find another
way than in other countries.
Yeah, these are some figures.
How many athletes do we support?
It's over 900 athletes,
most top athletes who
get supported very
broadly and then
also a lot of young athletes,
who we support on their way
to the top, which
is a crazy struggle.
You just heard some
of my struggles,
and you can imagine how
hard it was for my family
to find the financial support
to get three kids to the top.
My brother is in World Cup, too.
And there are many
families like that,
who really try to find a way.
And it's not always easy to
find the money, especially now
that sports is getting more
and more professional on a very
young level already.
And we really try to
give the athletes also
the peace of mind and
parents the peace of mind
that they have a support
system and the back net who
is holding them up,
so they can focus
on what this most important
to get their performance
and to go and get
some more medals.
Yeah, the figures
are always crazy,
like how many athletes are
well below wage minimum,
it's really astonishing
also for us every year.
We do the figures, and
it's not changing much.
So we really have
to support them,
and we have to find a way
to give them the security
to support them
in doing their job
and do what they can do best.
So thank you very, very
much for your attention.
It was a pleasure to talk
to you some about me,
some about our
amazing organization,
our organization that was
part of the Swiss medals
in Pyeongchang last winter.
We can see two of
our medal winners.
Those who followed
the Olympic games
might recognize Mathilde
Gremaud and Sarah Hofflin.
Both medaled at the women's
slopestyle event, gold
and silver, and all
the Swiss medal winners
were supported by Sporthilfe.
So the money is really going to
the those athletes that need it
and those athletes that
are working hard and going
for the medals.
95% of all athletes that were
at the games for Switzerland
were supported by
our organization.
And I think this is--
yeah, those are the nice
figures that we like to tell
and that we are
also very proud of.
So thanks for your attention,
and hopefully, now we're
going for some super
interesting questions.
I'm excited.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: I think we have
some Dory questions already.
Questions people submit before.
So what techniques did you
use to overcome mental blocks
after your injuries?
DOMINIQUE GISIN: Different ones.
And I think the most
interesting part about it
is not what tools I used,
but that I had to figure out
after every injury a new tool,
because no two injuries were
alike.
There were injuries
where I came back
without no mental problems.
And I was thinking, well,
what is this mental barrier
that everybody is talking about?
I don't know what it is, and
then there were other injuries,
and sometimes there were
really minor injuries,
where I struggled so hard,
and I had to find a way.
And there were
different strategies.
We did externalization that
I really talked sometimes
with my respects.
We did [INAUDIBLE],, where
I visualized a lot of races
without trying to crash.
I had times where
every time, I would
visualize a run in my mind,
I would end up in a net.
And that's not what
you're looking for, right?
You really want to
go to the finish.
So then I had to train.
I had to train my mind to
think the right things,
and I think two most important
points regarding this question
is always figure out the
way, and always question
if the one way that
worked the last time
will still work this time to
overcome a mental barrier,
and then the other is
it's mental training.
It's not mental magic.
You cannot think, I
will do it one time,
and then everything is good.
It's not working like that.
You really have to sit
down and do it every day
and use the techniques that
you find in a lot of books,
and there's tons of great
and amazing motivation books.
There's tons of great
and amazing mental books,
but the thing is you've
got to do it yourself.
You cannot just read the book,
and then everything is done.
It's not working like that.
First on a groomed slope
or a big powder day,
these days, no question.
Always powder days, and
probably, always was like that.
I mean, of course,
before skiing was my job,
and then you just
had those times
where you had to do your job,
and I always loved my job.
But on a day, on a free
day, I would always
prefer powder, for sure.
If you live in
Engelberg, you have to.
I would get exiled
from my village
if I would say something else.
I'm pretty sure I would.
[LAUGHS]
SPEAKER 1: You don't want that.
DOMINIQUE GISIN: No, I
don't want that either.
SPEAKER 1: It was
actually this past year
you said that your sister
won the gold medal.
DOMINIQUE GISIN: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: So what
was that moment like?
DOMINIQUE GISIN: It
was pure emotions.
And as I said before, it
was much more emotional
than my own victory, because I
was able to allow the emotions.
When I won, I was still somehow
in the adrenaline of the race.
And you know, I was
extremely happy.
And I was crying and everything.
But it was not as
quick after the race.
It took me some time
to realize everything
and to put everything in order.
And now with my sister,
I mean, I already
knew when we were
going there that she
had a pretty big chance
to win that race,
and then I followed her
whole journey very closely,
and the last 24 hours were not--
I mean, she crashed in
the downhill the day
before in the finish.
And the day after was that race
that we build up everything
for in the past three years.
And then you were right
there, right beside her,
and you cannot do anything.
I cannot hold her hand
when she's skiing.
And I cannot ski myself, as
she's doing it better anyway.
So I don't have to.
And then you just sit there,
and after we had the downhill,
she did really good downhill,
and then the slalom came.
And before the slalom run,
the American moderator
asked me how I felt
about my sister,
and I said, she's going to win,
or she's going to straddle,
because in slalom you
can always straddle.
But I was so sure.
And then I was just hoping
that she would not straddle,
because it can always
happen in slalom, right?
So every game, like oh, oh!
Then yes, it was beautiful.
AUDIENCE: My question is it
seems that skiing is always
about winning.
If you not score first place,
second place is already losing,
it seems to me.
So sort of two questions.
One is, what happened
if in Sochi, you
had had second place
and not first place.
And the second question
is is it a good thing
to become second best of the
world at the Olympics or not?
DOMINIQUE GISIN: I think
it's with all single sports,
like that, right,
it's first, and then
there's pretty much nothing
after for the public response.
And I'm saying that.
So nobody remembers who
was second in cycling world
championships four years ago.
Do you remember?
I don't remember.
Somebody remembers?
Maybe if you're a super hardcore
fan, but most people don't.
Now, the question that
is maybe more interesting
is what does it mean
to you as an athlete?
And I think for
me, as an athlete,
as I said before is the most
valuable thing if I can perform
at my best, if I can ski
at my full potential,
and if I have a run
like that, I'm happy.
And then what the board
says is something else.
And of course, you want the
board to be pretty much in line
with your own feelings.
But if you ever have the
chance to review Sochi, my run,
I'm coming to the finish,
and I knew that day
that I had a big chance to win.
I just knew it.
I was on the start.
I was super nervous.
I was sick because I pushed
myself really to that point
where I could be
first again in speed.
And it took me a lot of energy,
because after all the injuries,
my body just refused
to be fast in speed,
and it refused to lose control.
And you need to
lose control if you
want to win a downhill,
part of the control.
But part of the control,
you have to give up.
So in that position
on the starting gate,
it's not a comfortable place.
I felt really sick,
and I felt tired.
The last thing that was
in my mind was I'm tired,
and it's in the starting
gate, not in the finish.
But this is the mental part.
Then the body was fit, and
the body executed perfectly,
automatic, because I build it
up for years for that moment.
And then I promised myself from
the start, if you come down,
you look down at the snow, and
you think for a second was it
all I was able to give?
Did I execute like I wanted to?
If the answer is
yes, I have to live
with whatever is on that board.
I have to.
Of course, I can complain
afterwards and 100s there and--
I mean, we were same timing,
Tina Maze and me, 0, 0, 0.
It's pure luck.
I'm not going to tell
you anything else.
It's pure luck.
I could have been 0, 0, 1.
And we knew it's going to
be a tight race, because we
had five training runs.
Everybody knew the course.
Everybody was adapted
to the conditions.
Everybody had the skis
adapted to the conditions.
We knew it's going to
be hell of a tight race.
That was clear.
And I'm not saying
1/10 was luck,
but 100th, it's pure luck.
And that's what I wanted to
make sure for me, as a person
and as an athlete, that
I could live with it,
because as you said,
in the end, it's just
gold and then nothing else.
And I'm confident
to say that I think
I could have lived with
silver just as well,
and not the public response
would have been otherwise.
I wouldn't be at Google today.
I'm pretty sure I wouldn't.
But to me, as an athlete,
what is the most valuable
is the path and
all the experience
I took with me through
all these years.
And I can tell you these
days, I still have flashbacks.
I have so many flashbacks
of my former life.
I'm sitting somewhere and I'm
thinking, oh, I'm in Ushuaia
and it's raining,
and I'm training.
Or I'm in Lake Louise.
It's minus 32 degrees.
It's just too cold.
I had not one single
flashback when I was standing
on the podium in Sochi, never.
Not one single dream,
because as a person,
of course, what the public
thinks of me is important.
But as a person, it's not the
thing that was most important.
The thing that
was most important
was that I was able to
push myself to that point
to that sick feeling
on the start.
That is the flashback I get,
because that is my achievement.
And then the black white
results and the gold medal,
that's karma, or that's,
in the end, pure mechanics.
You can figure it
out by physics law.
But to me, the valuable
thing is really
the journey and the
feelings that put in there.
The energy I put in.
Does it answer your question?
It was a long
answer, but I think
it's a very important
question that
has no short answer for me.
AUDIENCE: Since you
participated in several tourneys
in many years, any loss of
performance that hurt the most?
DOMINIQUE GISIN:
Loss of performance--
AUDIENCE: Or a loss or
basically for any performance
in all your tourneys
that hurt you
the most in terms of how
the performance turned out?
DOMINIQUE GISIN: Oh, very easy.
Vancouver 2010, the Olympics.
It was heartbreaking.
I mean, I was so sure
I'm going to medal there.
Before the season, I had an
amazing season the year before.
I had my first two
World Cup victories.
Everything was set up.
We started to train in summer.
I was starting to be almost
as fast as the men's team.
The men's coaches
started to record me.
That was the biggest
achievement I ever had,
when the men's coaches
started to film me.
And then we had
one super fast ski,
and we were so confident for
the Olympics, we put it aside.
I didn't use it for one
single World Cup race,
because we just wanted to
be sure that it was still
OK at the Olympics.
And the season started off well.
I podiumed.
I did great results.
And then we went
to house, horrible
weather just one
single training.
And I always used--
that was one of the
methods mentally
that I used the trainings to
adapt myself to the slope.
So I was always pretty
slow in training, just
to get the right
feeling with the slope,
and when I felt comfortable,
I was able to charge.
And then in the training,
I was super slow.
And we had only one training.
Usually, we had two or three.
And then in the race, I
was 30 kilometers per hour
faster than in the training.
And I couldn't
handle the situation.
I got over the last
roller and crashed,
tore my meniscus, and also not--
I didn't tear my ACL, but
I injured it pretty badly.
I got surgery the same evening,
because we had only four weeks
left to the Olympics.
And I did not lose
hope one single second.
I was still believing in that
medal, all the journey through.
Next day, in the gym I did
everything for that path back.
Two weeks later, I was on the
start of a World Cup race,
and it was crazy.
I mean for me, it was
like OK, two weeks ago,
I was in the surgery
room, and now I'm
at the start of
a World Cup race.
And still, I was
able to handle it.
I was 17th at that first race,
which was amazing two weeks
after the surgery.
And then I went to Vancouver.
And I still believed I
could medal, not 17th, which
already would have been crazy.
But I wanted to medal.
Then again, horrible
weather, only one training.
And then I still believed in it.
The hill was crazy,
because it rained so hard
that it iced up in a way
that everything was shaky.
And then I got over the
last roller of the race,
and I got there with
the fastest split time,
and I crashed five meters
before the finish line.
I was like, that
cannot be right.
I mean, I gave--
if it would have
been a poker game,
I would have bet my house,
my car, like everything
I own, OK, my soul on that race.
And then I was lying
there in the finish
area with a concussion,
and I could not believe it.
And that's the one single time
in my career, where I really
was like I'm not going
to make it anymore.
It's just too much.
And then fortunately, I had
surroundings that supported me.
I had organizations
that supported me,
and they got me
out of this moment.
And that's also something
super important.
You will not be able to manage
all the setbacks yourself,
probably.
And it's always good to have
somebody, a net behind you that
just keeps you standing up.
SPEAKER 1: So who is in
that net, that support
system for you?
DOMINIQUE GISIN: My family
is super important to me,
especially having siblings
that have the same dream
and also went the same path was
absolutely crucial, because I
never had to explain
myself at home.
I mean, I understand each
and every one who's asking me
why the hell did you do that.
I mean, sometimes looking
back, it was pretty crazy.
But it was also amazing
that neither my parents,
nor my grandparents,
nor my siblings
would ever ask me that question,
because they just knew why,
because they have
the same passion.
They have the same
fire burning in them.
And it's crazy to do top sports.
It's just a huge
risk that you take.
And you're going out there,
and you're competing.
And as you said, only the
very best will survive.
And that's one single person.
It's not two.
It's not three.
It's not 10.
In the world.
Think about it.
Think about if you would have to
compete with each and every one
in the world who is doing
your job, would you be top 30,
top 20?
I don't know.
I mean, I would not
be top 30 in my job.
I'm pretty sure I wouldn't.
So if you do sports,
only that counts.
And even for that, you
have to fight as hell to,
as we saw before, to
have an income that
is minimum in our minds,
which is crazy for me.
And the value that the athletes
create for us, I mean, probably
each and every one, otherwise
you wouldn't be here, once
was sitting in front of
a TV and loving sports
and loving the emotions
that they gave us
and loving the experience of how
sports is bringing us together,
no matter if you're Swiss
or Austrian or American
or wherever you come from.
It's such a value
that is created
and I think this value should
also be valued, you know?
And that's something
which is super important.
And then, for me, I have
that in my surroundings.
But that's not every athlete
has a family like mine.
It's not something that
you can take for granted.
And also, not every family
has the possibilities
to finance something like
that for three kids, which
is super crazy.
And my parents did
amazing sacrifices.
If I look back and I
think, I mean we were not
in vacation for many years.
And I never thought about
it, because for me, it
was perfect as it was.
But to my parents,
it was a choice.
And my parents choose
to support us and choose
to live all these
crazy emotions with us.
And I think they
never regret it.
[LAUGHS] But still,
it's a choice.
And not every parent
would take that choice.
So yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Do you want to
ask your question in the mic
so we can hear it.
AUDIENCE: My question
relates to this risk.
So basically, downhill is
a very, very fast sport
with a non negligible chance
that you will either seriously
hurt yourself or even die, and
you probably had like hundreds,
maybe even thousands
of training runs where
you achieved those speeds.
Were there times when you
pushed yourself so hard
and when you were so tired
that you lost pretty much
most control and you felt
like I, at this point,
am behaving in a way that
doesn't respect my life
and I should never do
such a thing again?
DOMINIQUE GISIN: I think it was
more when I was young probably,
especially because the
path that I went through
was a very special one, because
I missed all this time where
young athletes are built
up between 15 and 18,
where they get
adapted to the speed.
Usually you don't come--
my sixth race, my sixth downhill
race of my life, not World Cup
race, like sixth downhill
race of my entire life
was a World Cup race.
It's not what you should do
with athletes, really not.
And the problem for me
was, because I put myself
in this crazy situation
with all the injuries I had,
I had no more choice if I
wanted to pursue my dream,
because there was
nobody waiting for me.
I can tell you, there are a
lot of talents in Switzerland
when it comes to skiing.
Of course, we would
always take more.
But we have a lot of talent.
So when I got injured,
there was pretty fast
somebody else who took my spot
as the best in my age group
and then the second
best and so on.
So when I wanted
to come back, I had
to take every chance
that there was.
And of course, there
were some chances
that when I look
back at them, I'm
like, how would I ever
come to the idea to do it?
My first downhill was
on a World Cup slope.
It was a [INAUDIBLE]
race, like a race
a little below World Cup, but on
the slope after the World Cup.
And that's why I got
the spot, because nobody
wanted to race there.
Yeah, it's true.
And then what
should I have done?
Then I took it.
I took the spot, and I went
there with my last bib.
I had no idea what I was doing.
Like we watched that video these
days, and we laughed so hard.
But actually, it's not funny,
because I was completely out
of control.
I had no idea what I was doing.
My skis were just going
down the hill with me,
and somehow, I ended
up on second place.
Nobody knows why.
But it saved my career.
So would I do it like that?
No.
That's why I
accompany my sister,
because I don't want her to
get in the same situations.
And because I was so much
back in the whole development,
I had that knife on my throat
for a very long time, then
with the first World Cup race,
first world championships,
I felt I had to medal.
I was there.
And I felt like a
complete failure
when I was 22 years
old, and I didn't medal
at the World Championships.
And that was the
problem, you know?
And when you're young, you
get in these situations,
and of course, now I'm
30 plus, and I look back.
And I'm thinking, what
the hell was I thinking?
It was super irresponsible.
But back then, I
just wanted to race,
and I would nobody let take
that chance away from me.
And I was lucky enough
to have injuries,
which weren't that
serious, which
helped me extremely
to deal with it,
because for me, the pain I
felt in my heart and my soul
when I wasn't able to ski was
always bigger than the pain I
had in my knees.
And that's why the
choice was pretty easy,
paired with the naivete
of youth, I'd say.
And sometimes, it's good
to be young, you know.
And it's tough, I know.
And skiing has
horrible accidents.
And for the whole
community, it was just--
it was-- black days
what happened last year.
We lost two colleagues
on the slopes.
And I mean, I would not
think about that every day,
I must admit, before, that this
was really possible, because we
didn't have deathly
injuries in decades.
And now we had two.
And it's a slam in
your face, and you
start to think different.
And I hope that we will be
able to support our athletes
in a way that we don't have
to put them in situations
like I was, that they just
have a better build up,
because you only get
in situations like that
if the ladder is somehow broken.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DOMINIQUE GISIN:
Yes, because if you
look today at Giulia Steingruber
or Ilaria Kaslin, the gymnasts,
or also Simone Biles, for those
who don't know the Swiss ones,
if I look at them, I think
they're completely nuts.
I mean, if I would try to do
that, I would die for sure,
right?
But they were build up
like that for decades,
and their bodies were
built to learn that.
But you can only do that if
you do that in tiny steps.
So I think it's super important
to have support systems, where
the athletes can
develop in a way
where you don't put them
in situations like that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Equal opportunity,
equal pay between genders,
but also cultural background
is a big topic in our industry,
many other industries as well.
I'm wondering,
what's the situation
in professional
skiing and how do
organizations like Sporthilfe
tackle the problem?
DOMINIQUE GISIN: Yes, of course.
It's a big issue, and
especially, as a woman,
I feel it's an important issue.
I think we all
work the same way,
we should get paid the same way.
I'm lucky enough to come
from a sport which is pretty
big in female, just like male.
We have years already,
10, 15 years back,
where the international
TV quotes were better
at the women's races
than at the men's.
I don't think there are
many sports like that.
So we had years where there
were more spectators worldwide
for the women's races
than the men's races.
I was once at World
Championships.
I loved it, where
the women's downhill
was the most important race,
because Anja Parson was
a legend and a hero in Sweden.
And the women's downhill
was on a Sunday.
So I think we are in skiing
at a very lucky position,
compared to other sports.
But I think we all have
to work towards that,
and we can only work
towards that as a community,
and that's, for me, something
that's super crucial, something
which should be natural,
but also something
that will take some time.
I think we have to keep the
patience, and at the same time,
never lose the goal
out of our minds,
and of course, an
organization like us is not
making any difference.
That is sure the
first big thing,
because for us, there is no
difference in women's and men's
athletes.
And I think in the future,
it will be like that.
But we also have to
admit that, as I said,
there are still differences
in numbers of athletes.
So we need more girls in
sports, and that's also
something which we have to bring
into the minds of the parents.
That's why all the support
that Sporthilfe is providing
is super important also for the
society, because in the end,
it's the parents who decide
if their kids are getting
into professional sports.
And if the parents are afraid
of the risk over an injury
or afraid of the risk off of
what this means financially
to their kids in
the future, then we
will not get a lot of kids into
sports, be it male or female.
So we have to find a way
to support the athletes
in a proper way, such that--
I mean, I hear parents saying--
and I have to say it in German.
Forgive me.
[GERMAN] something--
I don't know the English word.
Solid, yeah, a solid profession.
I feel offended by that.
I mean, sorry.
If a professional athlete who
is amongst the top 30 in what he
is doing of all world, if that
is not a solid profession,
I don't know what is, you know?
And you create a value that is
so important for the society.
And if we still have
parents who think that,
then we have to work,
because we should
work that they think
it's a solid profession,
be it for a girl or for a boy.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: What advice would you
give to your 14-year-old self?
DOMINIQUE GISIN: Yeah,
when you look back,
you're always smarter, they say.
I wouldn't change too much.
I probably would try
to take away the knife
from the throat in my mind
a little more, because I
had much more time than
I thought I have left.
But that's only possible
with the experience.
So if I would be 14 , again I
probably would do it all over
and just hope that I
wouldn't get injured so much,
maybe change some of--
yeah.
No, I mean in the retrospect,
if you're just smarter.
But I don't feel I made
a really bad decision.
And it also ended
up here, you know?
And I got to do so many things,
only because I got injured.
I would never have gotten
into flying if I would not
have gotten injured,
because I just went
to do it because I was injured.
And then I had spare time
because school was a bit boring
without having the sports side.
And I went into flying.
And now I'm a pilot,
and it's amazing.
So everything is going
as it should, and I'm
super happy with my life.
So I would just say go for
it to my 14-year-old self.
AUDIENCE: What triggers you?
Competitors, your own will, or
refuse from somebody that you
cannot do this?
What is the trigger for you?
DOMINIQUE GISIN: My
trigger was always
finding my own boundaries.
I love the feeling when your
body is doing exactly what it
should do, when you trained
for something for four years,
and then you ski down the slope,
and every single movement, even
of your little toe
is just perfectly,
and you're exactly
in the moment.
You also have those
times where you work,
and four hours later, you
realize four hours passed,
and they just went by, right?
And I feel like these moments
when I'm completely myself
and completely there,
they are so valuable.
And I always experienced
that when I really push
my boundaries, and
I got to a place,
where I just have to
function, and I cannot--
I don't have the
extra amount of energy
left to think about what I do.
I just have to do it.
So for me, it was always
about experiencing
those moments, where
I'm at my absolute best,
or at my absolute max, where I
just perform at my max level.
And that's something which kept
me going through times where
I had no podiums,
because as I said before,
when you don't start, you
will not get a podium.
But it was also something that
maybe shortened my career,
because in the end, I could not
get motivated by adding more
victories to the board when
I was not finding something
to push my limits further.
And just to stay where
I was at and to stay
at the level I was at and
wait for more victories
and for more medals, it was not
something that triggered me.
But as you pointed
out, pretty subtle,
I think it's something
very important
that everybody has
their own trigger.
And it's super important
to know your triggers,
because it's what gets
you up in the morning.
So be aware of what gets
you up in the morning,
helps you to get
up in the morning.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Do you feel still the
fire inside you to this topic?
DOMINIQUE GISIN: I will always
feel the fire about skiing.
And now it's not anymore about
skiing fast down the hill.
But it's about the powder days
and just enjoying those turns,
when I'm just--
and I always ski
with people, or most
time, I ski with
people that are better
than I am in powder skiing,
and that pushes me extremely.
And then I'm, again,
in a situation
where I have to really be at my
max to just cope up with them.
And that's, again,
this amazing feeling.
And other areas of my life,
I'm still far away from my max,
I think.
I'm far away from
being my max pilot.
I'm far away of
being my max CEO.
So I'm really looking forward
to challenge myself every day
and to hopefully, experience
that fire in those areas just
as well.
But it would be crazy
to expect the same fire,
because it was an extremely
big fire that kept me going.
So I have to be thankful
to have other fires.
SPEAKER 1: I think that's
all we have time for.
Thank you so much.
I think it's so easy to
see a profile like yours
and be intimidated and
think, what have I done,
but to leave after your
talk feeling so inspired
and seeing how
incredible you are.
Thank you so much
for taking the time
to share all your
stories with us,
answer all of our questions.
We really appreciate it.
DOMINIQUE GISIN: Well,
thank you, everybody,
for giving me so much
attention and for also thinking
about amazing questions.
I think we had some questions
today that I never had before,
so that's always
very, very valuable.
And also never be intimidated.
I feel like every single
one is doing their path,
and I'm amazed by what
you guys are doing.
I mean, if I see my
colleagues at ETH programming,
and I'm still hawk, You have
you ever seen hawk programming?
Like it's not that bad.
It got better.
But I always felt
like 10 code lines
for me were like 3,000 for
my colleague's students.
So that is amazing to me.
And that's what it's all about,
like finding your own limits
in your own path with your own
fires, with your own triggers,
and really leave your
trail wherever it is.
So I think that's something
that each and every one of us
can do.
I don't feel it's super special.
Each and every one has
super special things.
So go for it.
Tell your 14 year
old, go for it.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.